okay so 42 is a maybe not such a special
number in mathematics but a very special
number in nerd culture good good good
good did you want to do something 42 yes
so you take a piece of paper it's very
thin let's fold this in half fold it in
half again fold in half again imagine
you can keep doing this and in reality
you can't keep doing this but imagine
you can keep folding in half and each
time you do it will double in thickness
and if you fold it 42 times that's
enough to reach from the earth to the
moon
you notice when 42 turns up you keep
noticing it but that's not really all
that remarkable since any two-digit
number will turn up one hundredth of the
time today we are in my office and we
are talking about numbers and when I was
asked about thinking about the number I
just realized that there is a number
that I see every day
when I enter my office and this number
is 42 because we are in this office be
42 42 is a maybe not such a special
number in mathematics but a very special
number in nerd culture 42 is the answer
to life the universe and everything if
you'll go on Google what is the answer
to life the universe and everything so
Google calculator gives you as an answer
42 42 is the answer to life the universe
in effort and I am a huge huge huge
Douglas Adams fan my favorite book is
the attackers Guide to the galaxy all my
favorite books are the trilogy of 5
books that mix of Douglas Adams work in
terms of a character called Arthur Dent
the author Douglas Adams a great comedy
writer wrote first a radio series called
The Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and
and in the in the show they built a
supercomputer a giant supercomputer to
work out the meaning of life the
universe and everything and after
millions of years it decided that the
meaning of life the universe and
everything was 42 at which point the
people who programmed the computer on
build a computer were rather
disappointed but the computer quite
rightly said well what's the question
and they said it's the ultimate question
the ultimate question of life the
universe and everything but what's the
question which is I think is a
completely valid - so then the idea was
to build an supercomputer which would
calculate the ultimate question and the
supercomputer was earth and we formed
part of humans form part of that that
added organic framework you ruin the
ending oh yeah we haven't watched that
you know if you really haven't listened
to or watched or read The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy books you haven't
lived so go out and get to get them now
perhaps slightly embarrassing confession
is that I used to be involved with the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
see fan club and I used to help run it
briefly just a few years ago when the
film came out I remember it's quite an
exciting time I don't see them anymore
it's a shame but there are more I know
more things about 42 than I really ought
to this number 42 is said to be a pranic
number I was a pranic number I can write
it for you
so a pranic number is a number which is
obtained as the multiplication of two
successive integers so for instance in
the case of 42 42 is equal to 6 times 7
these are one after the other and any
number which is like this is called
pranic for instance 2 times 3 3 times 4
and so on Douglas Adams I think chose
this number because it kind of has a
funny sound 40 all those oohs 42
it's a funny sound again if you go on a
web and if you read some of the articles
about 42 their arguments ranging from
well actually it's 1 0 1 0 1 0 and
binary which is you know a nice binary
number and in fact in the television
program that flush is open they say 42
you see the binary you'll find 42 comes
up a lot in comedy and in other shows
partly because of douglas adams and
because he used it but partly because
it's just a funny sound then there is
another interesting property which is
slightly more complicated about this
number and it is the fact that it's
defined to be a primary pseudo perfect
number I want a primary pseudo perfect
number Kevin what's that mean ok so
first of all you have to find out what
are the prime factors of 42 okay so
write down 42 as 2 times 3 which is 6
times 7 so these are its prime factors
primary to the perfect number is such
that the sum of the inverse of each
prime factor plus the sum of the inverse
of the number itself is 1 1 over 2 plus
1 over 3 plus 1 over 7 and
these are the some of the inverses of
each prime factor then plus one over the
number itself if you work out this
calculation you can put everything under
the common denominator the result is 1
there are not so many numbers that have
this property the next one after 42 is I
think 1806 and then you immediately go
to very huge number so it appears like
an innocent property but it's not the
story is he he sat he wrote it in his
garden he was sat in his back garden he
thought what number should I should I
choose it should be a sort of smallest
number it should be I so boring number 4
et will do and he picked for TT there's
also arguments that six times nine if
you look at that problem in base 13 I
pop the number 42 all these mad mad
things that Douglas Adams himself said
were absolutely bonkers
he said he chose 42 because it's a funny
number he thought it was a funny number
and then there is another for instance
another one which 42 belongs to is the
sequence of harshad numbers
Harshad is written like this so what is
a hard shot number is a number that is
divisible by the sum of its digits so
you have 42 take 4 plus 2 this is 6 and
32 is divisible by 6 so any number with
this property is called Harshad number
do you think it's funny number oh I
don't know it's it's an interesting what
I've gone for 42 I don't know what
number is funnier than 42 71
I don't know 68 if you're very bright in
mathematics and you participate in
international Olympia's of mathematics
and the total mark to achieve the
perfect score is set at 42 is that
coincidence oh he thinks I'm indeed
ampere as well this I don't know we need
to ask the people who are involved in
these committees but before Douglas
Adams there was already quite a lot of
attention on this number from works by
Lewis Carroll and you know
mathematicians have they are known to
have a
particular taste for recurrences and
nerdiness so to say so it may be that
this was chosen on purpose but I don't
know very well in the fan club magazine
they would have a column all about where
people have seen the number 42
yeah recently and it was a bit of fun
except one guy he didn't quite seriously
who actually thought there was a
mystical meaning behind the number 42
genuinely thought there was and he's to
go through the phone book and look for
multiples of 42 in people's know in
phone numbers
he used to define a finer multiple of 6
find a multiple of 7 multiplying
together oh look it's a multiple of 42
how amazing it really isn't that
remarkable if you look for things like
that
soon as I see there's an instant
resonance there when I see 42 and in
fact one of the experiments so I want to
do we're working with ticking a silicon
surface surface like this where we put
hydrogen atoms on it and then we take a
tip of a scanning probe microscope and
and remove the hydrogen atoms one at a
time and one thing I really want to do
is put 42 on a surface in atoms
Fox Mulder's apartment in the x-files
was apartment 42 which may have been a
reference to hitchhiker